at least the ushers in Germany's
Parliament can stick to their regular
routine they cordon of areas for TV
interviews and prepare for the upcoming
session otherwise nothing here is
business as usual Bundestag president
Roy blur voiced his concerns all state
power comes from the people the people
have spoken to us with these elections
and now we must act in accordance and
responsibly
[Music]
although the failed coalition talks were
not officially on the agenda Angela
Merkel was under close scrutiny today
would she try to persuade the Social
Democrat leader Martin Schulz to join a
new grand coalition that would be the
easiest way out of the gridlock but the
SPD doesn't seem willing to help the
Chancellor form a committee Rivaldo
Merkel has failed miserably with the
coalition she wanted she cannot lead
apparently she has lost her touch and
now Parliament can try by itself to make
progress perhaps will even be better for
the people the pro-business Free
Democrats have also had enough of Merkel
for the moment they walked out of the
talks on Sunday and although party
leader Kristian Lintner is due to meet
German president Steinmeier in the
afternoon he and other party members
seemed reluctant to go back to the
negotiating table until now nothing was
achieved in the talks we weren't able to
bring change and reform into German
politics it wasn't an easy decision but
it needed to be taken to avoid losing
credibility the greens meanwhile find
themselves getting closer to Myrtle and
her conservative bloc I think it will
make most sense for parties involved to
resume negotiating we are ready to talk
but at the end talking alone will not be
enough in order to form a stable
government Chancellor Merkel will have
to find a clear majority within
Parliament and many here believe the
only way to do that are fresh elections